.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Ich bin in die Schweiz gekommen,
um Asyl zu erhalten.
Ich wollte meine Familie
in Sicherheit bringen.
Ich hatte Angst, man würde mich
nicht ausreisen lassen.
Ich habe niemandem erzählt,
dass ich ausreise.
Nicht einmal Freunden.
Ich treffe russische Kriegsgegner
und -gegnerinnen in der Schweiz.
Wie sie habe auch ich
vor dem Krieg in Russland gelebt.
Ich habe als Korrespondentin für
das Schweizer Fernsehen gearbeitet.
Seit Beginn des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine
ist das für mich nicht mehr möglich.
Die russischen Kriegsgegner
in der Schweiz eint,
dass sie
nicht in den Krieg ziehen möchten.
Ich möchte nicht sterben
und ich möchte niemanden zerstören.
Die Menschen aus Russland
sind im Gegensatz zu mir
einer realen Bedrohung ausgesetzt.
Es war nicht klar,
wie sich die Situation in Russland
weiterentwickeln wird.
Es bestand die Gefahr,
in die Armee eingezogen zu werden.
Ich will verstehen,
warum russische Kriegsgegner
in die Schweiz gekommen sind.
Weswegen es für sie schwierig ist,
Schutz und ein neues Zuhause
in der Schweiz zu finden.
Jekaterina Sinitsa ist Ärztin
und hat Russland
im April 2022 verlassen.
Von Beginn des Krieges an war klar,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Ich gelangte zur Erkenntnis, dass
ich aus Russland ausreisen musste.
Ohne zu wissen, was mich erwartet.
Dass es für immer sein könnte,
habe ich damals nicht geglaubt.
Ich begleite Jekaterina Sinitsa
zu ihrem neuen, temporären Zuhause
in Fribourg.
Es ist ein Gefühl, als hättest du
die eine Welt verlassen.
Aber diese neue Welt
hat dich noch nicht aufgenommen.
Es ist, als ob du
irgendwo steckengeblieben wärst.
In der Schweiz angekommen
ist Jekaterina Sinitsa noch nicht.
Der historische Koffer.
Mit diesem Koffer
ist sie aus Russland ausgereist.
Es hat sich so ergeben,
dass ich hier drin
meine Dokumente aufbewahre.
Auch die Unterlagen
zu meinem Asylverfahren.
Sie zeigt mir,
was ihr die Schweizer Behörden
im August 2022 geschrieben haben.
Hier ist ein Teil der Unterlagen.
Dieses Dokument ist das wichtigste.
Es ist der Negativentscheid
auf den Asylantrag.
Hier in diesem Absatz
steht der Entscheid.
Mhm.
"Ihr Antrag auf Asyl
ist abgelehnt worden."
"Sie müssen die Schweiz verlassen."
Wie war das für Sie?
Das war grauenhaft für mich.
Ich habe das nicht erwartet.
Mir schien klar, dass die Gefahr
für alle offensichtlich ist.
Auch als Frau könnte sie in Russland
in den Krieg eingezogen werden,
denn sie ist Ärztin.
Alle Ärztinnen und Ärzte müssen
der Armee zur Verfügung stehen.
So verlangt es das Gesetz.
Viele meiner Kollegen unterstützten
die sog. Militäraktion.
Im Spital, in dem ich arbeitete,
wurden bereits
Brigaden für die Front gebildet.
* Düstere Musik *
Das SEM sagt, Asylgesuche
von Russinnen und Russen,
die glaubhaft geltend machen,
dass ihnen ein Kriegsdienst
bei der Rückkehr nach Russland droht,
werden zurzeit nicht entschieden.
Aus Sicht der Schweizer Behörden
ist die Gefahr für sie hypothetisch,
da sie bisher
keinen Marschbefehl erhalten hat.
Ich kann ihre Angst vor
dem russischen Staat nachvollziehen.
Ich habe in Russland selbst
Willkür und Repression erlebt.
Sinitsa hat sich in Russland
nicht getraut zu demonstrieren.
In der Schweiz angekommen,
nahm sie an Demonstrationen teil.
(Alle) Putin is a killer!
Putin is a killer!
Als ich in die Schweiz ging,
war ich euphorisch.
"Eine Demokratie."
"Hier kannst du
deine Meinung sagen."
"Hier kannst du demonstrieren."
Meine Motivation
ist meine Ablehnung des Krieges.
Daran hat sich nichts verändert.
Bei einer Ausschaffung nach Russland
würde mir
sicher ein Verfahren drohen.
Sie können dich heute
wegen allem anklagen.
Sie hat Beschwerde
gegen den Asylentscheid eingereicht.
Seit eineinhalb Jahren wartet sie nun
auf den definitiven Entscheid.
Wenn mein Französischlehrer
keine Worte findet,
wenn etwas
schwierig zu erklären ist, sagt er:
"C'est la vie. C'est comme ça."
Das sage ich mir selbst jetzt auch.
Am Dorfrand
von Dottikon im Kanton Aargau
steht diese Asylunterkunft.
Das neue, temporäre Zuhause
von Alexander Euler.
Er hat Russland
im September 2022 verlassen,
nachdem die Mobilisierung der Armee
ausgerufen wurde.
Seit November 2023 lebt er nun hier.
Der Ökonom hat Schweizer Wurzeln.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Alexander Euler zeigt mir seinen
Schlafplatz in der Asylunterkunft.
Herzlich willkommen.
Das ist mein Zimmer.
- Wie ist es für Sie hier?
Ja, es ist ...
... schon besser
als in meiner letzten Unterkunft.
Das war ein Bunker.
Das ist also schon viel besser.
Auch er hat Post
von den Schweizer Behörden bekommen.
Auch sein Antrag wurde abgelehnt.
Die Gefahr,
in den Krieg eingezogen zu werden,
sei für ihn
nicht grösser als für andere Russen.
Haben Sie das sofort verstanden?
- Nein.
Ich spreche kein Französisch.
Ich verstehe es
nur mit Google Translate.
Das Staatssekretariat für Migration
äussert sich nicht
zu laufenden Asylverfahren.
Zur allgemeinen Situation für
Kriegsdienstverweigerer aus Russland
schreibt die Behörde:
Er hat Rekurs eingelegt
und wartet nun
auf den definitiven Asylentscheid.
Können Sie arbeiten?
Ist es schwierig,
eine Bewilligung zu erhalten?
Mit Status N können wir arbeiten.
Aber es ist sehr schwierig,
damit eine Arbeit zu finden.
Ich könnte ja jeden Tag
eine Antwort erhalten
und muss vielleicht gehen.
Das möchten viele Arbeitgeber nicht.
Für ihn ist es schwierig, sich in
seinem neuen Leben zurechtzufinden.
Darüber zu sprechen,
fällt ihm auf Russisch leichter.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Ich hatte früher alles:
eine Wohnung,
ein Auto, ein Motorrad.
Hier habe ich nichts.
Das Schwierigste ist, dass wir
schlicht nichts zu tun haben.
Du bist als Mensch
noch voll auf der Höhe,
aber du kannst den ganzen Tag lang
nichts machen.
Du fängst an, darunter zu leiden.
Kurz gesagt: Du verdummst.
Nachdem Alexander Euler
Russland verlassen hatte,
bekamen seine Eltern
Post von der russischen Armee.
Darin wird er aufgefordert, sich
im Rekrutierungszentrum zu melden.
Laut russischen Gesetzen
kein Marschbefehl,
aber die letzten zwei Jahre
haben gezeigt:
Betritt ein Mann
ein russisches Rekrutierungszentrum,
landet er mit grosser
Wahrscheinlichkeit an der Front.
Alexander Euler sucht nach Wegen,
um in der Schweiz zu bleiben.
Er will versuchen,
in einem Bürgerrechtsverfahren
seine Schweizer Wurzeln
geltend zu machen.
Alexander Euler
ist ein Nachfahre von Leonhard Euler,
dem weltberühmten
Schweizer Mathematiker.
Nach ihm
sind zwei mathematische Konstanten,
ein Mondkrater und ein Asteroid
benannt.
Im 18. Jh. wanderte er für
seine Forschung nach Russland aus.
Alexander Euler sucht nun einen Weg,
n i c h t
nach Russland zurückkehren zu müssen.
Wie er genau vorgehen will,
weiss er noch nicht.
Artur Grigoriev
hat Russland im Mai 2020 verlassen.
Er lebt heute in Zürich.
Er hatte Angst vor einer
Mobilisierung in die russische Armee.
Er hat sich in Zürich
an der ETH beworben.
Artur Grigoriev schreibt hier
seine Doktorarbeit in Informatik.
Für mich - als jemand,
der in der IT-Branche tätig ist -
war es einfacher, auszureisen.
Ich habe eine gute Ausbildung.
Ich hatte keine grossen Probleme
auszureisen und Arbeit zu finden.
Aber für viele Leute
ist das überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Er forscht
zu computeranimierten Figuren,
wie sie beispielsweise
für Computerspiele entworfen werden.
Ich schreibe einen Algorithmus,
damit der Computer versteht,
wie sich Stoffe
während des Tragens bewegen.
Welche Teile der Kleidung
sich auf der Innen- und welche
auf der Aussenseite befinden.
Mit einem Modell soll die Bewegung
von Stoffen animiert werden.
Es ist eine schwierige Aufgabe.
Für seine Arbeit
braucht er keine der Landessprachen.
Deutsch, also allgemein
Sprachen zu lernen, mag ich sehr.
Was nicht bedeutet,
dass ich viele Sprachen spreche.
Aber es macht mir Spass.
Es fehlt mir einfach die Zeit dazu.
Neben seiner eigenen Doktorarbeit
kümmert er sich auch
um Studenten an der ETH.
Wo keine Zahlen und Algorithmen
gefragt sind,
kann er sich
auf Englisch verständigen.
Diesen beiden
Masterstudenten aus China
hilft er bei einem Artikel
für eine Fachpublikation.
Für Leute,
die ihre Doktorarbeit schreiben,
gibt es in der Schweiz
die höchsten Gehälter weltweit.
Der Unterschied,
wie gut du dir als Doktorand
ein komfortables Leben
leisten kannst, ist riesig.
Artur Grigoriev
will wegen der Willkür des Staates
nicht nach Russland zurückkehren.
Ich kann nicht mehr zurückkehren,
denn die russischen Behörden
lassen mich nicht mehr
als Journalistin einreisen.
Seit 19 Monaten
warte ich auf eine Antwort
aus dem russischen Aussenministerium.
Ich wollte Sie fragen,
ob es Neuigkeiten dazu gibt,
warum ich
keine Akkreditierung erhalte?
(Mann)
Ich kann Ihnen keine Antwort geben.
Ihr Antrag ist in Bearbeitung.
Ich bin abhängig
von den russischen Behörden.
Es gibt keine Transparenz,
keine Auskunft, keine Gesetze,
auf die ich mich berufen kann.
Mir ist, als würde in Europa eine
neue Mauer stehen. Unüberwindbar.
Wiktor
hat Russland im März 2022 verlassen.
Ohne einen Plan zu haben,
wie es mit ihm weitergeht.
Wiktor ist Kameramann und hat mit mir
in Russland zusammengearbeitet.
Wir sind zusammen für Reportagen
weit gereist.
Die Arbeit schweisst zusammen.
* Dynamische Musik *
In Russland untersteht auch Wiktor
der Wehrpflicht.
Er reiste deswegen keine zwei Wochen
nach Kriegsbeginn aus Russland aus.
Ich hatte
ein absolutes Chaos im Kopf.
Es war schwer zu verstehen,
was eigentlich geschah.
Meine Familie hatte Angst,
dass ich bei der Ausrufung
des Kriegszustandes
in die Armee
eingezogen werden könnte.
Er ist
für ein paar Tage in der Schweiz.
In Meikirch in der Nähe von Bern
ist er zu Besuch bei einem Freund.
Er macht sich bereit
für einen Dreh am Nachmittag.
Wo sich die Gelegenheit bietet,
sucht Wiktor Arbeit.
Wie fühlst du dich vor dem Dreh?
Hier filme ich keine Nachrichten.
In Russland habe ich
v.a. Nachrichten gefilmt.
Das färbt darauf ab, wie du filmst.
Heute Nachmittag
filme ich für ein Projekt,
mehr im dokumentarischen Stil.
Das ist einfacher.
Bs-bs-bs-bs.
* Dynamische Musik *
Wiktor und Bernard sind befreundet.
Heute hilft Wiktor
Hobbyfilmer Bernard bei Aufnahmen.
Und Bernard
übernimmt die Kommunikation.
Sie drehen einen Film
für die Gemeinde Aarberg.
Es ist nicht perfekt aufgeräumt.
Darf es etwas lebendig sein?
- Ja, sicher.
Wiktor ist sich Arbeit unter deutlich
schwierigeren Bedingungen gewohnt.
Schau,
wir können hier eine Totale filmen,
auf der alles zu sehen ist.
Die vier Stühle.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Wir haben uns
in Russland kennengelernt.
An einem Schweizer Musikfestival.
Wir sind in Kontakt geblieben.
Er hat auch eine Zeit lang
in Russland gelebt.
Seit Wiktor Russland verlassen hat,
fühlt er sich wie ein Nomade.
Solange ich keinen langfristigen
Aufenthaltsstatus habe,
kann ich nirgendwo
einen festen Job finden.
Aber ich muss arbeiten.
Deswegen packe ich
jede Gelegenheit am Schopf,
um wenigstens
ein klein wenig Geld zu verdienen.
Wiktor
ist einer von 900'000 Menschen,
die Russland
seit Kriegsbeginn verlassen haben.
Ich reiste an verschiedene Orte,
um zu arbeiten.
Zuerst war ich in Polen,
jetzt bin ich in Prag.
Ich weiss nicht,
was als Nächstes kommt.
Vielleicht ziehen wir wieder um.
Ich schicke meinen Lebenslauf
an verschiedene Firmen.
Danke.
Um in der Schweiz auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt Chancen zu haben,
fehlt es ihm an Sprachkenntnissen.
Die Arbeit als Kameramann
fordert von dir,
dass du
mit den Leuten kommunizieren kannst.
Als Kameramann musst du
mit dem Regisseur und dem Kamerateam
interagieren können.
Obwohl ich Erfahrung habe ...
Mein Deutsch ist nicht sehr gut.
Aber ich lerne.
Okay, danke schön.
Jedes Mal, wenn Wiktor
in der Schweiz zu Besuch ist,
geht er hier in diese Zeltsauna.
Für Wiktor ist die Sauna
ein Ort der Zuflucht in der Ferne.
Wiktor hat mich
in die Sauna in Meikirch eingeladen.
Für ihn ist die Sauna ein Tunnel
in die eigene Vergangenheit.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Das ist eine tiefe Verbindung
mit meiner Heimat.
Es hilft mir dabei,
nicht in eine Depression zu fallen.
Wie es für ihn sein muss,
seine Heimat zu verlieren,
kann ich nur erahnen.
Für mich war Russland immer
nur eine Station in meinem Leben,
aber nie meine Heimat.
Ich bin sehr nostalgisch.
Die Sauna
ist wie ein Licht im Dunkeln.
Während ich für 1,5-2 Std.
in der Sauna schwitze,
fühle ich mich so, als wäre ich
in meinem Dorf in Russland.
Sosehr ich nach Hause fahren möchte,
sehe ich im Moment
keine Möglichkeit für mich.
Wenige Monate nach Kriegsausbruch
konnte ich Wiktor
mit einem Visum unterstützen.
In der Schweiz niederlassen
kann er sich damit nicht.
Vor Kurzem hat er eine Aufenthalts-
genehmigung in Polen erhalten.
Eine Ausschaffung nach Russland
droht ihm nicht.
Ich bin wieder zurück
bei Jekaterina Sinitsa.
Sie geht mehrmals in der Woche
in den Sprachunterricht.
In Fribourg bietet ein Verein
Französischunterricht für Migranten,
Asylbewerber und Geflüchtete an.
Mit Jekaterina Sinitsa
lernen hier auch mehrere Frauen
aus der Ukraine Französisch.
Die Ukrainerinnen im Kurs sprechen
dieselbe Muttersprache wie sie:
Russisch.
Donc:
"... pour préparer
nos devoirs de français."
Monsieur, une belle phrase, non?
In der Pause haben sie Zeit
für private Gespräche.
Die Russin hat sich mit den
Ukrainerinnen im Kurs angefreundet.
Ich verstehe ganz gut Ukrainisch.
Warst du mal in der Westukraine,
in Lviv?
Nein, noch nie.
Ihre Herkunft
war ihr zu Beginn unangenehm.
Ich versuchte, anfangs
nicht zu sagen, woher ich komme.
Wozu die Leute
zusätzlich traumatisieren?
Der Hintergrund der Leute
ist hier unbekannt.
Es könnte sein,
dass jemand Verwandte hat,
die getötet worden sind.
Wir sollten tolerant
und vernünftig sein.
Umso mehr,
da sie die Ukrainer unterstützt.
Für Geflüchtete aus der Ukraine
gibt es einen Sonderasylstatus.
Ich stelle fest,
dass es im Unterschied dazu
für Menschen aus Russland -
gemäss heutiger Praxis -
hohe Hürden gibt,
um Schutz in der Schweiz zu finden.
Pendant que vous écrivez
les phrases en tableau ...
Am Wochenende zu Hause
bei Artur Grigoriev.
Er informiert sich
in unabhängigen Medien
über die neusten Entwicklungen
in Russland.
(Moderatorin) Sieben Jahre
muss eine Frau ins Gefängnis,
weil sie Sticker
gegen den Krieg aufklebte.
Was ist Ihre Reaktion darauf?
Schlimmer
kann es gar nicht mehr werden.
Der russischen Justiz
bleibt bald nichts anderes übrig,
als Frauen auf dem Scheiterhaufen
zu verbrennen.
Es geht darum, alle anderen im Land
einzuschüchtern.
"Entweder ihr geht ins Gefängnis
oder ihr haut ab."
Welche Gefühle lösen die Nachrichten
aus Russland in Ihnen aus?
Die Nachrichten aus Russland
sind traurig und grauenhaft.
Aber ich versuche, mich
diesen Gefühlen nicht hinzugeben
und nicht in Panik zu verfallen.
Wer sich in Russland
gegen den Krieg äussert,
muss in Kauf nehmen,
dafür ins Gefängnis zu kommen.
Alle unabhängigen Medien
mussten das Land verlassen.
Er wohnt in einer Einzimmerwohnung.
Er ist allein
aus Russland ausgereist.
Ein Teil meiner Verwandtschaft
ist noch in Russland.
Viele Freunde sind noch in Russland.
Deswegen könnte es durchaus sein,
dass ich irgendwann
nach Russland zurückkehren muss.
Ich werde mich darum
auch hier im Interview
nur vorsichtig
zu allen Themen äussern,
die eine Strafverfolgung in Russland
zur Folge haben könnten.
Er hat sich in Russland für
die liberale Opposition engagiert.
Seine politische Haltung
bringt ihn in Gefahr.
Ich schreibe in den sozialen Medien
offen
über meine oppositionelle Haltung.
Es kann gut sein, dass jemand,
der meine Texte
in den sozialen Medien liest,
mich als Regimegegner einstuft
und mich deswegen
bei der Polizei denunziert.
Solange ich nicht muss,
versuche ich deshalb,
nicht nach Russland zurückzukehren.
Für die Zukunft
würde ich mir wünschen,
dass in Russland
eine Demokratie herrscht
und ich dorthin zurückkehren
und als Forscher arbeiten kann.
Sehr viele intelligente Leute
haben Russland verlassen.
Es wird sehr schwierig werden -
selbst wenn es
einen Regimewechsel geben sollte -,
die Menschen davon zu überzeugen,
nach Russland zurückzukehren
und etwas aufzubauen.
In seinem neuen Zuhause in Zürich
unter Menschen zu kommen,
fällt ihm schwer.
Ich begleite ihn am Samstagabend
in ein Restaurant.
Ich bin nicht sehr gut darin,
mit jemandem in Kontakt zu kommen.
Neue Freunde zu finden.
Aber ...
... ich arbeite im Moment daran.
* Sanfter Pop *
* Sie singt auf Russisch. *
An einem Konzert einer russischen
Sängerin findet er Gleichgesinnte.
Die Sängerin hat wie er Russland
nach Kriegsausbruch verlassen
und kritisiert den Angriff
öffentlich.
(Alle) Nein zum Krieg!
Voraussichtlich in einem Jahr
wird er die Schweiz wieder verlassen,
weil er eine akademische Karriere
verfolgen will.
Wenn ich nach Abschluss meiner
Doktorarbeit an der ETH hier bleibe,
habe ich schlechtere Chancen,
später Professor zu werden.
Es gilt als wichtig, an möglichst
vielen Orten Erfahrungen zu sammeln.
* Applaus, Jubel *
Ich bin wieder bei Alexander Euler.
Er nimmt mich mit an einen Ort,
mit dem ihn viel verbindet.
Hier ist es wie zu Hause.
Das ist meine zweite Heimat.
Oder wie sagt man auf Deutsch?
Seine Vorfahren haben hier
in Riehen bei Basel gelebt.
Auch mehrere hundert Jahre später
sind hier
Spuren der Familie zu finden.
Können Sie uns vorlesen,
was hier über Ihren Vorfahren steht?
Ja. "Leonhard Euler,
Mathematiker, Physiker,
Ingenieur, Astronom und Philosoph,
verbrachte in Riehen
seine Jugendjahre."
"Er war ein grosser ..."
"... Gelehrter
und ein gütiger Mensch."
Jetzt komme ich als Asylant hierher
und ich kriege
einen Negativbescheid.
Das ist natürlich
sehr traurig für mich.
Leonhard Euler ist vor 300 Jahren
aus der Schweiz
nach Russland ausgewandert.
Obwohl der Mathematiker
nie nach Basel zurückgekehrt ist,
hat er das Bürgerrecht
für sich und seine Kinder behalten.
Alexander Euler sucht nach Unterlagen
im Staatsarchiv der Stadt Basel.
Er ist nicht der Erste der Familie,
der um den Aufenthalt in der Schweiz
kämpft.
Verwandte von ihm
sind mehr als 100 Jahre vor ihm
aus Russland geflüchtet.
Dank der Abstammung
von Leonhard Euler
haben sie
ihr Bürgerrecht wiedererhalten.
Ob ihm dies auch gelingen wird?
Er muss auch hier wahrscheinlich mit
einem langwierigen Verfahren rechnen.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Er fährt regelmässig am Wochenende
auf Besuch zu Verwandten.
Zu seinem Schweizer Verwandten
Peter Euler
pflegt er seit Jahren den Kontakt.
Wir haben
nicht gerade das schönste Wetter.
Ja ...
Aber es ist okay.
- Schnee haben wir auch nicht.
Dafür ist es schön warm.
Die Weihnachtstage verbringt er hier,
bei Verwandten am Genfersee.
Wegen seines hängigen Asylverfahrens
kann er nicht hier wohnen.
Hallo.
- Hoi. Saluti, Alexander. Salü.
So.
Das ist Schokolade für deine Mutter.
Okay, danke.
- Sie schickt immer russische.
So schicken wir
ein bisschen was zurück.
Als Alexander Euler
in die Schweiz kam,
hat er zuerst hier gelebt.
Er hat
viele Bewerbungen geschrieben.
Es ergab sich aber nichts Weiteres.
Dann musste man sagen:
"So, jetzt steht Asyl an."
"Du musst Asyl beantragen, sonst
bist du illegal in der Schweiz."
Das war ein bisschen: "Ah,
jetzt muss man das doch machen."
Er sah ganz anders aus,
als er angekommen war.
Er war
so ein sorgloser, junger Mann.
Er dachte nicht viel.
Die Welt war schön.
Das hat sich ein bisschen geändert.
Das Asylverfahren habe ihm zugesetzt,
meint Béatrice Euler.
Sie unterstützen ihn,
wo immer möglich.
Auch Peter Eulers Vorfahren
sind aus Russland geflohen
und haben vor 80 Jahren das Bürger-
recht in der Schweiz wiedererhalten.
Peter und Alexanders Verwandtschaft
liegt weit zurück.
Peter Euler
zeigt mir den Stammbaum der Familie.
Wir sind so
mit Leonhard Euler verbunden.
Und er ist so verbunden ...
- Von Kristofor.
Alexander, Alexander ...
... Dimitri und ich.
Ich denke,
er muss in der Schweiz bleiben.
Da gibt es nichts anderes.
Er ist ein Euler.
Letztendlich ist Leonhard Euler
nicht irgendjemand.
Er hat der Schweiz
auch viel Ruhm gebracht.
Alexander Euler wird
die Wiedereinbürgerung beantragen.
Und gegen den negativen Asylentscheid
hat er Rekurs eingelegt.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Bei unserem ersten Gespräch
wirkt Alexander Euler verzweifelt.
Jetzt wirkt er gefasster.
Unabhängig
vom definitiven Asylentscheid:
In den Krieg ziehen will er nicht.
Auch wenn ich
nach Russland zurück muss:
Ich gehe nicht in die Armee.
Ich gehe lieber ins Gefängnis
als in den Krieg.
Jekaterina Sinitsa hat in Fribourg
erste Freundschaften geschlossen.
Mit Mary Wenker ist sie
regelmässig in der Stadt unterwegs.
Um den Schweizer Führerschein
zu bekommen,
hat Jekaterina Sinitsa im letzten
Sommer mit ihr das Fahren geübt.
Fahrstunden mit Mary Wenker
sind ihr in Erinnerung geblieben.
Ich bin jedes Mal so geschwitzt,
als würde ich Sport machen.
"Ich bin geschwitzt"
oder "Ich habe geschwitzt"?
"Ich habe geschwitzt."
Mary Wenker
ist Schriftstellerin von Beruf.
In ihrer Freizeit
engagiert sie sich für Geflüchtete
und lernte so
auch Jekaterina Sinitsa kennen.
Sie kennen viele Geflüchtete,
aber Jekaterina Sinitsa
ist speziell für Sie. Warum?
Sie ist speziell für mich,
weil sie versucht,
nicht vom Schweizer System
abhängig zu sein.
Alles, was sie macht,
um ein Dossier zu haben.
Das zeigt ihren Integrationswillen.
Alle Anstrengungen,
die sie unternimmt,
um die Sprache zu lernen.
Die Sprache ist schwierig.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Jekaterina Sinitsa versucht,
in Fribourg anzukommen.
Auch wenn sie noch nicht weiss,
ob sie hier bleiben kann.
Sie musste sich Medikamente
gegen Depression verschreiben lassen.
Die Belastung wurde zu gross.
Dieses Warten ist unerträglich.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
was besser ist.
Dieses Warten, oder?
Ich habe Angst, noch einmal
eine Ablehnung zu erhalten.
Was würde ein zweiter
Negativentscheid bedeuten?
Die Ausschaffung.
Offiziell
wurden Ausschaffungen nach Russland
seit Ausbruch des Angriffskrieges
nicht gestoppt.
Ich kann ihr ihre Angst nicht nehmen.
Russische Kriegsgegnerinnen wie sie
finden bis jetzt
kein neues Zuhause in der Schweiz.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024